we're going to be going over the chess
game of the century and it was played
between Donald Burn and Bobby fiser you
may not have heard about Donald Burn you
may have seen this game before Donald
Burn is an international Master a very
strong International Master at that um
and so a lot of you may see this and say
you know Bobby fiser should win this
game easily but you have to keep in mind
that this game was actually played when
Bobby fiser was 13 years old so as we
kind of go over the moves and analyze
them and come up with some of the
thoughts behind some of Bobby Fisher's
move it's going to be just mind-blowing
to think that a 13-year-old can come up
with some of the stuff that Bobby fiser
was coming up within this game burn from
here played Pawn 2 D4 again trying to
control the center and Bobby fer castled
on the king